for her time Diane was very exceptional
women wanted to get married and have
kids
[Music]
setting up karisoke II and studying the
gorillas and living that whole kind of
life was completely not how she was
brought up she was not raised in an
animal-loving family she followed her
own path very soon in life
she had aspirations to work with animals
as a vet but she didn't get the grades
so she ended up working with children as
an occupational therapist which he did
for her must have been ten years
so she'd already had a successful career
before this complete change of direction
[Music]
she wasn't doing it to get academic
credentials the paleoanthropologist
Louis Leakey was looking for somebody to
go start a long-term study of gorillas
he had helped launch jane goodall's
career I'd already decided that I must
study gorillas before first meeting dr.
Leakey after a brief interview he
suggested that I become the gorilla girl
he had been seeking and our conversation
ended with his assertion that I should
have my appendix removed before
venturing into the remote wilderness of
Central Africa Leakey mentioned the
possibility of having to have her
appendix out and she booked herself
right in for the operation he was
shocked but clearly it convinced him
that this one might stick she was very
determined
[Music]